all right listen it is no secret that i
am a major beauty junkie so we are
teaming up with one of my favorite
retailers that we are fortunate enough
to sell flower beauty in it is hyvee
and we're here to answer a few beauty
related questions from a viewer take a
look hi drew
so i have a holiday party coming up and
i just wanted to know if you had any
tips on how to make it look like my skin
is just like glowing
um if you also had any tips on how to
deal with this little guy here that
would be greatly appreciated okay thanks
well guess what i have got some answers
for you okay i would like to show you
our light illusion concealer it's
actually what i wear on my face every
single day britney i'm going to show you
a little trick
so what you want to do is you just want
to feather out the edges if you're doing
it around a little you know blemish or
pimple and then
once the wetness is completely set
that is when you powder otherwise you're
going to change
the color and you're going to kind of
water the opacity down but that's how
well this concealer works it just got
rid of a tattoo
so
you use that concealer
and that blemish is going bye-bye
all right
that's number one number two you
mentioned something about a golden glow
now this is actually the best-selling
item that we have at flower beauty it's
called the supernova
celestial skin elixir now
this
is going to give you an instant do now
you can either just pat it on your face
or you can mix it with your foundation
it will never coagulate and it will
never move your makeup around
and you don't even have to powder with
it if you want to avoid your oily tea
because sometimes you don't want to glow
there just put it in the areas or put a
drop into your foundation or liquid
bronzer there's nothing that this can't
do
now if you want a little holiday pop of
color
you can also take this little blush bomb
this is also one of our best sellers so
i wanted you to kind of have some of our
best products in practice
and you just move it around the cheek
like that
and because it's this gorgeous gel it's
going to keep that dew as opposed to a
powder that's going to give you quite a
different result
another thing that i love doing is going
up high right here it gives you actually
a tiny little bit
of a face lift what without having a
mess with your face if you know what i
mean
i've never messed with this
and i plan on not doing that because i'd
like to age
gracefully
okay
now i've shown you a way to get the
dewiness with liquid and gels i now i'm
going to wipe this off because i'd like
to show you how to get
dewyness and sparkle with a dry powder
so this is where you're gonna grab your
powder blush okay this is our shimmer
and strobe palette
we actually started making this very
early on and it has been a bestseller
for us sometimes depending on what
lipstick or blush you're wearing you're
going to want to go for more of a
champagne pink or a gold or a pearl it's
really about like what tone suits the
rest of your makeup best but let's see
which one am i going to go with today
pick one you guys pick
i think i hear gold but i did hear a
champagne all right so here i go
you can do that tap tap tap and then i'm
going to go straight
like that
see that
yeah baby
make sure you don't miss that brow bone
then you go across the bow
don't forget the bow of the lips
okay there you go
so britney
i hope that all these flower beauty
products which i'm sending to you
personally as soon as this segment is
over
and these are all available at hyvee and
i'm so proud to show you the latest
issue of our magazine because guess what
right there
is our hyvee
because not only are we proud to sell
flower beauty and hyvee but the best
part about partnering with them is
getting the chance to help feed families
in need this holiday season hyvee is on
a mission to end hunger by donating five
million meals to families in need
and you can help too
visit www.hivdeals.com
and they will be donating it to feeding
america i actually just shot a
commercial for them and if you go to my
social channels and the show website i'm
very proud to feature it on there so i
hope that helped brittany happy holidays
[Music]
you